Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new spiderman no way home marvel video
there was obviously a brand new logo teaser that
was released everybody's been going crazy about
because everyone's been on high alert looking for
the spider-man no way home trailer for the past
couple of weeks so i'll explain what's going on
with this because it does look very familiar to
some other multiverse bass glitchy logo title
scenes in recent series but if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's going to be so much spider-man
stuff happening in the next couple of years like
in the next couple of months it's going to turn
into the year of spider-man because we have venom
2 we have the morbius movie coming out in january
and in between them spider-man no way home to
say nothing of spider-man into the spider-verse
2 which is coming out next year as well that
doesn't even include all the other spider-man
spin-off movies that sony is making but recently
you probably saw sony's official south american
account released this new spider-man no way home
title teaser which ordinarily would seem pretty
normal but during that everyone noticed a very
familiar easter egg it glitches the same way the
spider-man into the spider-verse titles glitch
in the first movie they also released a version
of the spider-man into the spider-verse 2 teaser
that glitches way more between all the different
logos just to noting the different versions of
spider-man that they're going to feature during
the movie they did the exact same thing with
glitchy titles for the wandavision series just
to denote that something wasn't quite right with
reality like things would be going crazy during
the series you were meant to question the nature
of reality and they're doing the exact same thing
with a slightly different twist on it during the
loki series with the titles shifting between the
different characters in loki's name just to
reference the alternate timelines which are
alternate universes in the loki's series different
versions of the loki character that we're going
to meet because it is marvel's first legit 100
percent multiverse based series whereas before
they just kind of hinted at multiverse concepts
and just tease the idea the producers on the loki
series also confirmed that it's meant to set
up doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness and
that is supposed to have some connections to
spider-man no way home because that's also
sort of linked with what's happening in doctor
strange 2. the same way that the Wandavision
producers confirmed that those episodes were meant
to have some connection and influence on the plot
of spider-man no way home and doctor strange too
like everything is connected but the common theme
here is the trope of the multiverse now the way
that each of the different series like the way
that Wandavision treated some of these tropes and
the way the loki series is treating it is a little
bit different but you get the idea it's all about
the multiverse the thing is though is that after
the sony account posted this to their twitter they
deleted it really quickly but they also posted it
to some of their other social media accounts
the exact same video and it's still up on some
of those alternate accounts so i don't know why
they would delete it off their twitter but then
leave it up all the other places that they posted
it but if you slow this down to actually see what
the different glitch frames are the new no way
home glitchy title glitches to a larger version
of the title like it pops out then it changes to
a deep red version of the title and the subtitle
also bounces in and out changing between different
shades before going back to the official logo that
they released in the teaser trailer earlier this
past year the funny tom holland spoiler teaser
where he's like they told me the fake title
again i don't know why they keep telling me
the fake title i don't give away spoilers but
as you would expect there were a lot of people
going full vision meme like there's this cool
charlie dave version of the meme with spider-man
no way home in the title scene just wondering if
there are any specific easter eggs or references
in these glitches but if you haven't re-watched
those other spider-man movies in a while their
title scenes in all the tobey maguire spider-man
movies and both of the andrew garfield amazing
spider-man movies the logos themselves were
actually more metallic silver looking and it
was the backgrounds that would change from
sequel to sequel like if you really reached
hard and wanted to bend over backwards making
some link between this and the other versions
the closest link i could think to make with a
deep red glitchy version of the no way home logo
would be the deep red background of the spider-man
2 logo we do have confirmed alfred molina as his
version of dr octopus coming back with the special
de-aging technology the way that he explained it
just to make him look the exact same he was almost
20 years ago during that movie because he is quite
a bit older now but if you take a step back like
if you really think about this in a bigger context
i think the glitch here is just meant to generally
reference the crazy reality warping concepts like
we are going to shake the foundation of reality
in the spider-man marvel cinematic universe movies
sort of playing into the larger theme of the
loki series the way they're talking about
nexus events alternate timelines alternate
realities the multiverse in general that whole
secret wars backstory that they explained i did
a big video for that so i'll put a link in the
description because they did this big intro
scene where there's a massive info dump and
they're teasing a bunch of huge future projects
that they're not going to pay off right away
like this is loki we're talking about so the idea
is they do solve some of the problems that they
set up during episode one but in doing so probably
cause a lot of new problems and then uncover some
really big revelations that shake the foundation
of the mcu the way that kevin feige talks about it
kevin feige himself when they were doing press
for the loki series and some of the other loki
producers said that their episodes more than
any of the other marvel phase projects so far
will affect all the future marvel phase 4
movies including spiderman no way home by
causing these big ripple effects with the way
they're messing with timelines in the multiverse
we know for a long time that kevin feige considers
the sony spider-man spin-off movies like venom 2
the morbius movie to be in a separate universe
and that tom hall and spider-man would not only
be traveling the multiverse eventually he'd be
traveling between cinematic universes there was
a recent interview that somebody did with tyrese
about the morbius movie where he tried to explain
that morbius was inside the mcu but i think that
he's also mistaken because during that interview
he also claimed that morbius was coming out in
october and they've already moved the release date
to january so be careful when you're listening to
some of the actors sometimes the actors will get
real confused about the details that's why they
don't want them talking too much not only just
to not give away spoilers in general everybody
looking at tom holland but also because a lot
of times actors won't completely understand how
the movies are all connected to each other and
how some of these easter eggs work but what it
seems like marvel is trying to do just in general
working hand in hand with sony and this because
of their big sharing arrangement the way they
weave these characters together and share the
spider-man character is using the loki series and
spider-man no way home to build out a better map
a better explainer for how the multiverse works
with all these movies and explain the notion of
the spider-verse in how tobey maguire spider-man
movies and andrew garfield's amazing spider-man
movies how venom carnage are all connected
in a single continuity like how all this can
co-exist in a really easily understandable way
so it's more a question of how much spider-verse
we're going to see in how soon we're going to see
it like how much andrew garfield and how much
toby maguire are we actually going to see
in these upcoming movies probably not as much
as you think like there's been all kinds of
crazy rumors about this multiverse version of the
sinister six with willem dafoe's norman osborne
green goblin coming from the toby films and
putting this multiverse sinister six team together
i would love if that's true but right now that's
just a rumor but when you think about it no way
home is still meant to be a tom holland movie
even though there's been all these jokes about
him just being a small cameo inside the movie
because of all the other characters that they've
announced so in terms of spider verse i'm really
just expecting references easter eggs very short
cameo scenes like very light touch the only reason
why i think that doctor octopus and electro are
big deals in the movie is because of the way
those actors have talked about their characters
as if they're main characters whereas if we see
toby maguire or andrew garfield if that really
does wind up happening they'd be more like smaller
cameos with the idea that if everything works out
and they do actually want to come back in a bigger
way we'd see that in future movies if you've been
following all the spider-man news for the past
couple of years about the movie it sounds like
toby maguire has been the most reluctant to rush
back to spider-man but most of the other major
sony social accounts around the world the past
few weeks have been updating their banner art
for their profiles to be spiderman no way home
official artwork also recently sony's official
account in india started posting really cryptic
teasers of their own these emojis are just meant
to represent spider no way and home with a zipped
lips emoji like we're not giving away any secrets
and the official spider-man no way home twitter
account itself have been posting way more recently
it's almost as if they were trying to tell us
that they're about to do something really big just
preparing everyone for big reveal so of course it
should go without saying i think sony's prepping
all their accounts to start officially promoting
the movie and drop the trailer but here's the
thing the official spiderman no way home twitter
account's most recent post is basically saying
chill my dudes a lot of us were expecting sony to
do something for tom holland's birthday since that
fell right at the beginning of june but because
spider-man no way home isn't hitting theaters
till late december you have to remember that most
studios don't release their really big trailers
until about six months before the movies come out
so that's why sony probably isn't going to release
the actual spiderman far from home trailer till
july sometime they didn't really have any giant
comic book movies that were coming out in june
but marvel is releasing their first big marvel
phase four movie in july so it just makes sense
that sony would wait for all that hype to start
building up before dropping the trailer i don't
know if they actually plan on attaching the
trailer to the black widow movie but that's when
you would want to keep your phones on 24 7 with
alerts enabled if you're not already doing that as
for spider-man no way home connections to venom 2
larger multiverse stuff going on the way that andy
circus talked about it the way the president of
the sony studio talked about it sounds like tom
holland is not going to be in venom 2 they'll
just have some references and easter eggs to
spider-man but i think that's about as far as
it's going to go maybe some more legit references
in easter eggs and post-credit scenes but the sony
president said when you watch this movie you won't
miss spider-man and i think that's his way of
saying that like you're not going to see a ton of
spider-man happening in this movie it's just going
to be venom and carnage for the most part but he
did say that after spider-man no way home we would
have like a really fundamental understanding of
how tom holland is going to connect with all these
other versions of spider-man in the multiverse
like how they're going to explain him eventually
crossing over with venom so i would take that
as soft confirmation that there will be a lot of
multiverse spider-verse elements in storytelling
in spider-man no way home once we actually do
get that first trailer then i'll start doing some
more bonus videos for the multiverse and how this
is all connected to the loki episodes and what
they're setting up with the marvel multiverse but
hopefully that explains what's going on with all
the weird postings that the sony social accounts
have been doing the past couple of weeks and these
weird spiderman teasers they've been releasing
my next big video will be my full loki episode 2
video that'll post wednesday morning so make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss that
everyone click here for my full loki episode 1
video and click here to learn why the infinity
stones don't work anymore on the loki series
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!